and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead Jess
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time career transformation bro simply
learn industry expert
live data
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
didn't choose a quick fix he just added
data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder day ho night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situation you too will find your way to
get ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in
progress
hi folks uh we'll be starting the free
career master class uh in few minutes uh
I can see a lot of introductions coming
in on chat here uh as we start the
session so uh like it's fantastic to
have you on board uh I'm rasia I'm all
the way joining from Bangalore India and
I'm thrilled to be a host today uh you
can drop us a hello on the chat here let
us know your name and where are you
tuning in from um we can have a little
bit of conversation on the chat here
before we start so in this session we'll
be talking about stepping into AIML in
2024 pitfalls and how to navigate them
uh we already have our speaker Here With
Us Jeremy Samson uh welcome
Jeremy uh before we start let me quickly
take you through the ground rules here
uh so if you have any question for our
speaker here you can uh put down those
questions in the Q&A box it's very easy
to navigate right now we are having a
conversation on the chat box here and
it's just beside the chat box the Q&A
box so due to the volume of messages we
get on chat so we might actually miss
your query there so please help help us
out by putting on your questions in the
Q&A box and we'll make sure to address
all of your queries uh towards the end
of the session the session is been
recorded in case you want to go through
the recording of the session uh once
again uh you can expect a follow of
email with recording link webinar
certificate and also a bonus offer for
attending this webinar for the program
part will be which we'll be talking
about uh in the upcoming uh session uh
also to request a proof of attendance
for this webinar you can enter your name
into post webinar survey uh that is
something you'll be getting once the
webinar ends and uh in case you want
your full name in the webinar
certificate so make sure to fill the
post webinar survey if you have any
questions about the webinar surve we can
answer that towards the end of the
session we'll take some time for that so
uh let us know if you have any questions
about the ground rules here uh this uh
webinar is powered by simply run a
world's number one online boot camp uh
we are very proud that we have been in
the digital skills training space for
almost 13 years we have advanced almost
5 lakh plus careers in over 13 plus
countries and we have 800 plus qualified
trainers we have have category of
diverse courses uh AI machine learning
which we'll be covering today data
science business analytics cyber
security project management product
management and many more categories
which we cover so uh before we start uh
let me quickly take you through the
agenda of today's uh webinar here so
obviously we'll be getting to know a
little bit more about you how we can
help you out better in your career uh if
you're here basically you are an AIML
aspirant here you're interested in
basically uh moving towards IML or you
have questions about IML career in
general or about the program we will be
covering uh we will be talking about
stepping into AIML in 2024 and about
careers in AI machine learning in 2024
the hottest skills the hottest career
Parts you can take up uh so and also
what is the UT boot cam we'll be
covering um about that as well and also
learner outcomes uh enrollment steps of
the program and the Q&A part uh so
there'll be a special duration for the
Q&A part so in case you have any
question questions you can let us know
in the Q&A box and we'll try to take as
many questions throughout the session uh
but in case we are not able to address
it we'll address it towards the end of
the session also for the webinar
certificate you need to stay till the
end of the
session so uh please make sure to do
that uh moving on as I said that we'll
be getting to know a little bit more
about you so uh let's start with a quick
poll here so the poll uh here says that
how many years of experience do you
currently have so you can select uh from
any of the four options which is the
most suitable for you I'll just read it
out for you so the first one here is
currently studying second one 0 to three
years of experience third one 3 to 5
years of experience and the last one
more than five years of
experience so as I was speaking folks
have already started sharing their
responses on the poll here that's great
it's always good to know right like
folks who are joining us uh What uh
experience uh of timeline they come from
also I see a lot of introductions coming
in start here as we uh have started the
session uh so I can see stepen has
joined from Maryland USA I can see um GB
Hamilton has joined from Texas USA I can
see D has joined from Atlanta and uh I
can see Phil has joined from New
Jersey uh I can see someone has joined
from Saudi Arabia Pano has joined from
Nigeria and uh Steve has joined from
Boston and AD
is joined from
Cairo uh as we can see that folks have
joined not only from the US but also
different countri so that's great keep
the introductions coming in it's always
good to network right these events
before we start so let's get to know
each other each other a little better uh
and as we were speaking uh actually we
have gotten most of the responses on the
poll here so I'll just give last five
seconds more for the poll how many years
of experience do you currently have
please let us know on the quick poll
which you see on the screen here
so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll
and also share the result with you folks
uh as we can see that 45% of the folks
who have joined us have more than five
years of experience and uh completely
opposite of it we also have 43% of the
folks who are currently studying so
that's interesting uh and we have few
votes for Z3 years of experience and 3
to 5 years of experience as well so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us we have gotten a really active uh set
of audience here and as we move ahead we
already have a speaker Jeremy Samson
here with us uh Jeremy first of all
would like to welcome you and thank you
for taking the time out uh for this uh
webinar today the master class today and
we have an interesting session lined up
we'll be talking about AIML so would you
like to give us your introduction to the
crowd
here yeah absolutely um so uh good
morning or good afternoon everybody
wherever you are I actually uh find it
very cool seeing in the the chat just
that we have a lot of people coming from
a lot of different places around the
world uh so very cool I think this is
probably the most diverse crowd we've
had uh actually for one of these so uh
but yeah I'm Jeremy Samuelson uh I'm
joining you from Atlanta Georgia I see a
number of you are actually also in
Atlanta here with me that's cool uh so I
have actually
been uh in Industry as a data scientist
and machine learning engineer for a
little over 15 years uh my 15-year Mark
or an iers was back in July um and uh
yeah I've worked in a number of Industry
sectors I spent the first three years
about of my career uh doing analysis in
hospitals for healthcare um to help
different hospitals optimize their
patient throughput or their nurse staff
uh scheduling all that kind of stuff uh
then transitioned into Financial
Services was in financial services for a
long
time uh not a lot of years um then kind
of took a little detour uh did some
research for a little bit uh with a
startup out of Silicon Valley um
transitioned into Supply Chain
management and some Logistics work for
another three years um and then
presently I find myself back in
financial services it's a fun space to
be in um so yeah and I'm primarily
working on uh fraud detection actually
in my my current role so uh yeah so I've
seen a lot of different things things uh
I've dealt with a lot of different types
of clients in a lot of different spaces
and uh yeah it's been fun so I'm excited
for all of you who are uh looking to
start your journey in this this
space uh thank you so much Jeremy for
your introduction and once again welcome
to the master class here uh as we move
on uh we'll be talking about how how
basically stepping into AIML in 2024 and
what are the pitfalls and how you can
navigate them uh and also uh folks if
you have any insights or any basic
basally suggestions ideas or you know
about this topic you can let us know in
the chat here feel free to share we
basically love having a conversation on
the chat here so uh let's start so uh
let's start with rap rapid technological
advancement tell
me uh yeah so I would say that's
definitely a real challenge about this
field uh is that it moves very rapidly
and I would say that's always been true
actually while I've been in industry
that you know I've never felt like it
was easy to keep up with everything that
was going on uh but I would say right
now
especially um things really are moving
fast things really are changing a lot uh
so I'm sure all of you were aware uh you
know that open AI released uh chat GPT
in November of last year so a year ago
now um that
actually is and has been the fastest
growing application in history their the
time that they took to reach 100 million
users is the fastest that we've ever
seen uh
so this uh kind of exposure now that the
public has to deep learning to large
language models uh to generative AI uh
has really led to this kind of you know
massive wave of interest uh that that
people have people want to learn about
it clients want to you know know how it
can benefit them they want people who
have the expertise to be able to
implement this kind of solution for them
uh and also there's just a lot of uh
research being done not just in the
advancement of how these models work to
make them better but also people are
just kind of thinking in all sorts of
different
directions uh in terms of like what
could you apply this to right like how
like what industry sector could you
apply this uh to how could you apply it
so um yeah that kind of uh sort of
mental flexibility I think has is very
important and has taken a lot of time
and energy uh in the past year to kind
of keep up with all the changes that are
happening
absolutely let's move on to the next
slide uh so we we'll talk about data
quality and ethical concerns you know
which is again like one another thing
you know which is pretty uh
trending yeah absolutely uh I would
say data really is kind of the the thing
that determines who has the greatest
success right so in all these sort of
arms races that are out there with data
and with uh machine learning and AI uh
it really does come down more than
anything to who has access to more data
and data of higher quality uh you know
because there are all these things um
you know so it mentions here in the
slide that data may actually be noisy it
may be biased uh and all of these
different machine learning and deep
learning and AI uh related Solutions uh
can be very swayed by that I'm sure many
of you have heard the term like garbage
in garbage out uh that's absolutely Ely
true so as powerful and as elegant as a
lot of these algorithms are they really
do rely on high quality data so uh
that's a big thing um and then also we
as data scientists and machine learning
Engineers have to think very carefully
about what sorts of data do we want to
include in our analyses and what sorts
of data do we want to include in our
models um so that's certainly been an
ethical concern I think uh in examples
where say machine learning and AI have
been applied to uh the criminal justice
system right to determine whether an
inmate gets paroled um or to determine
what kind of sentence uh a defendant
should be assigned or things like that
um you know there have been cases where
you know researchers have found uh
systemic unfairness um you know systemic
biases in those in those models that
have been applied and a lot of that sort
of comes down to again what types of
variables do we choose to include as the
the scientists and Engineers who build
those types of systems so that's also a
very important thing to
consider uh thank you for sharing that
with us jimy let's move on to the next
slide here so modern
in yes uh this is a huge topic actually
a huge topic that that's very a very Hot
Topic in research right now is this idea
of explainable AI uh or interpretable
AI uh you know many of you probably have
heard that uh with deep learning right
with deep neural networks being able to
interpret what specifically is going on
like you know being able to kind of make
real you know practical sense of the
inner workings of a neural network uh
has you know until now actually been Out
Of Reach for us and in fact to a degree
it still is uh it's still very very
difficult to do very well um and in you
know kind of General applications right
in some applications such as computer
vision it's actually easier to get a
good sense for what layers are doing or
um you know to kind of get a sense in
terms of the meaning of what different
hidden layers are about um but yeah in
general this is still very very hard and
that's actually led to sort of the the
rise of an entirely new class of model
that we also refer to as explainer
models uh so you guys can see on the
slide there's lime or shap um which shap
I would say is
probably uh the most in use kind of like
the most uh broadly used that you'll see
uh it's one that I actually use daily in
our fraud detection models uh so we have
to have you know clear explanations
right so for example you have a consumer
apply for some kind of line of credit uh
the issuer of that credit checks with
our model to see if we suspect that
identity fraud is happening and if we do
they may choose to not approve that
account if that uh consumer is dened for
that that account right for that line of
credit they actually are owed an
explanation about you know why did you
guys deny uh my my credit application
and we have to be able to give real
explanations um you know you can't just
say well our our magical AI model said
you couldn't have a said you couldn't
have a credit card uh you actually do
have to you know give you know real
explanations about what what it is that
you saw in their application um and as
much as possible actually we try to give
what are called counterfactual
explanations which is uh that you can
kind of say in this particular case if
this variable had been this instead of
that this you know this actually might
have led to a different result so you
can really kind of explain like um you
know why certain things sort of led to
the the decision that you got out of the
model so yeah uh very exciting that's
actually a huge huge thing that we're
seeing develop a
lot yeah um thank you so much for taking
us to that and also let's talk about
hardware scalability and Resource
Management in the year 2024
for yeah this is also a big one this
actually has been a big one I think
for uh you know since the beginning in
machine learning and AI so maybe some of
you have seen this or heard of this that
back in the 1950s there was an algorithm
developed that was called the
perceptron in the early 60s there was
actually a news story that was printed
about how scientists were speculating
that within a handful of years that
model would become self-aware it would
be able to replicate itself that
basically in every way it would
seemingly be like artificial life not
just artificial intelligence um
obviously that didn't happen uh so
that's also a thing there's been AI hype
from the beginning uh as well but um
yeah I think a big part of that uh kind
of why that prediction was so wrong is
because scientists back then I think
grossly underestimated the amount of
data it would take to actually develop
these models and train them but also the
amount of compute power right and they
they were very limited in terms of the
compute power that was available to them
uh so that's always been kind of a
limiting factor for the progress and the
development of deep learning and AI um
today we're finding that that is not the
case as much right with the Advent of
all these really convenient Cloud
platforms such as AWS Microsoft Azure
Google Cloud platform and all of the
sort of uh I don't know maybe like you
know the next tier down things like IBM
uh or digital ocean some of those other
ones that are out there uh so that's
still a thing that we have to care about
though or that we have to think about
because even though technically the
compute resources are there uh you you
do have access to them in a sense uh
like you know or at least they exist
today which is a thing that hasn't
always been true um but now we actually
have to think about how are we being
efficient in the utilization of those
resources because any company you work
for is going to have a monthly budget
right of like how much can they spend on
cloud resources and things like that um
and it definitely becomes a problem for
them if you are you know kind of in you
know in your goal of scalability if you
exceed the budget so we have to kind of
think about scalability but we also kind
of have to think about efficiency and
sort of like the the budgeting concerns
around that kind of stuff as well for
sure oh thank you so much for sharing
interesting insights uh on hardware
scalability and Resource Management uh
moving on uh let's we'll be talking
about careers in Ai and machine learning
in 2024 so uh basically as we can see
these are the hottest AIML career paths
which you know over which open up in
2024 can you take us through these
career paths
here yeah absolutely
um so to be honest anywhere you go there
actually may be some
fuzziness at the borders between these
right so you know if you try too hard to
kind of clearly Define like well what
does a machine learning engineer do
versus what does the data scientist do
you may be a little surprised or
frustrated when you go to work at a
particular company and maybe your job
title is data scientists but then they
also have you doing some stuff that you
think maybe a machine learning engineer
would do not not uncommon at all um but
broadly at least um we'll start with the
data engineer actually so the data
engineer kind of is like the foundation
for a lot of that stuff so as a data
scientist or as a machine learning
engineer or you know someone who builds
AI
models ultimately you can't do anything
if you don't have access to data and if
you don't have you know real trust in
that data set in terms of how accurate
it is how reliable it is and the people
who actually
um make sure that you have that are the
data Engineers so the people who build
an optimize data databases build
pipelines for data that flows between
databases or from the database to your
model um all of that is done by the data
engineers and the data engineering
team uh and yeah without them we
wouldn't really be able to do any of
this other stuff they they should be
walking around wearing capes as far as
I'm concerned because yeah they they
kind of make it all happen um aside from
that you have the data scientist who
again this is a little bit variable
depending on where you go um But
ultimately they are responsible for then
you know once you've got the data
engineer who's built this beautiful ETL
pipeline for all the data the data
scientist is then responsible for making
sure we get meaningful insights out of
that data uh which is kind of the point
of the whole thing right the sort of why
businesses invest uh in data and data
architecture and things like that um so
what a data scientist does could be
highly varied it could be that you're
making reports or dashboards to just
share insights with
uh you know decision-making stakeholders
in terms of like what's happening in
their department or you know in their
sort of segment of the company and what
should they do in certain
situations um it often does involve
statistical modeling or machine learning
uh because really um honestly a lot of
the time a particular process and what's
happening in a process is actually quite
nuanced and so you can't always get at
it with just you know kind of like these
nice simple visualizations quite often
to really get to the bottom of what goes
into a process how would you optimize it
all that kind of stuff you have to build
a model for that process so and that
could be anything it could be machine
learning could be like some kind of
agent-based simulation it could be some
type of like stochastic like operations
research model so you know there are a
lot of things that could go into that um
in some places if you're a data
scientist and you've built a model you
may also be expected to have to deploy
it yourself kind of depends on the
budget uh for you know the size of the
company you're in and all that kind of
stuff however it's becoming more and
more common that in more companies
you're actually not as the data
scientist expected to deploy your own
work or deploy your own model so as the
data scientist you'll kind of get that
model to sort of like a proof of concept
step uh now after that if it actually
needs to be scaled up to ingest larger
volumes of data or you know data at a
higher velocity um you know and there's
some kind of ETL pipelining that has to
be done to kind of plug the model into
the whole you know operational system
that it's supposed to work with um so
that's sort of a different skill set but
this is someone who also still needs to
understand uh how machine learning works
so that they can still ensure that the
model that was deployed is at least
logically the same as the model that was
sort of handed to them as a proof of
concept even if they had to change it to
make it say faster or to you know handle
different kinds of operational error
situations or whatever so that person
then is the machine learning engineer
who kind of takes the proof of concept
model from the data scientist gets that
deployed uh and operationalized as part
of the you know sort of operational
system uh and then within artificial
intelligence uh you can have these
different roles the AI developer or AI
architect which again in different
companies may actually look IND
discernible from a data scientist or a
machine learning engineer um but also in
certain companies like uh like Facebook
is one example or I guess meta now sorry
um where they have a role that's like a
machine learning scientist or an AI
scientist uh and these are actually the
people that kind of really deep dive
into the theory of how these models work
and so that's out of these types of
teams you'll see actually the
development of like new original models
like again using the example of meta um
currently they have llama which is their
large language model but before that
they had Facebook profit which is uh a
very powerful uh time series prediction
model um so they do have scientists that
and researchers that actually develop
original models uh as
well so yeah that would be my breakdown
of those four those are some interesting
career paths to take up in inl thank you
so much for taking us to that Journey
now moving on to the hottest skills in
IML
2024 uh yeah absolutely so all of these
are actually I think quite big uh
computer vision's always been big um I
think I think largely the thing that
drives computer
vision is autonomous vehicles so uh in
order for the car to be able to uh you
know see what is around it identify
different things pedestrians other cars
Lane
boundaries uh all that kind of stuff
that all falls under computer vision and
that really is sort of the the Crux of
you know what you have to achieve there
um time series analysis uh very huge in
the finance sector and will continue to
be for uh ever right uh so trying to
forecast what's going to happen in
different markets right uh equities
markets Bond markets commodity markets
that kind of thing um let's see uh let's
see if we can kind of pick out some that
are especially big so yeah cloud
computing distributed computing again
because of how big the data sets uh are
becoming uh and how big some of these
models are becoming uh that's definitely
becoming
a more hotly desired skill set in fact
to give you some idea the desktop that I
have it's in another room um actually
has four gpus uh so again Hardware
acceleration is kind of a big part of
that as well so you might use gpus
instead of uh just your normal CPU so I
have four uh Nvidia RTX 8000 gpus in
that machine so in total I have about
four or 48 gabt of video RAM or vram uh
and there are models I've used that
actually are still just the model itself
before you think about any data set you
would feed through it just the model
itself is um bigger than the amount of
vram that one uh GPU has and so you need
to find ways to distribute the model
itself over multiple chips um so yeah
that's absolutely becoming uh a really
you know really big thing uh neural
architecture
search huge area of research and has
been from the beginning as well so um
the architecture is a pretty nebulous
term in neural networks so it could
refer to and well does refer to this but
is not limited to this to all the things
I'm going to tell you um the number of
hidden layers that you have for the
neural network uh how many neurons are
in each hidden layer and they don't have
to all be the same so each layer is kind
of like its own sort of set of
parameters um are you going to
regularize the model if so what's the
methodology you're going to use are you
going to use Dropout if so what's the
dropout rate are you going to use like
LP regularization in that case what's P
what's Lambda um what are your
activation functions do you are these
densely connected layers are they
convolutional layers or recurrent layers
or residual layers or something else
so uh yeah so basically what this leads
to is your sort of hyperparameter space
that you're searching for sort of the
optimal architecture in your neural
network is massive it's very high
dimensional very very difficult to find
an optimal solution uh within such a
high-dimensional space so uh yeah this
basically any work that could be done to
like make this easier or make this
faster um really anybody is like trying
to get their hands on kind of a better
answer for how to do that it's very very
difficult very computationally intensive
and I would say actually this one thing
more than anything else this neur neural
architecture
search is what has led to so much
advancement in the other things on this
list like the AI optimized hardware part
about gpus and tpus cloud computing
distributed computing um all of that
kind of stuff really is largely
motivated by just how computationally
intensive it is to lock down what is
that optimal setting of all the
hyperparameters involved in in your your
uh neural network
architecture uh those are some
interesting skills to take up ANL 24 uh
just this is a most asked question I
just want to put it out there jery uh is
AI going to affect the cyber security
jobs because as we can see uh one of the
hottest skills you know here in 2024 is
AI driven cyber security can you tell us
a little bit about that good or bad yeah
so I don't know if it's going to take
anyone's job in cyber
security um but it definitely is playing
a bigger role in cyber security these
days um and I think it kind of makes it
so that even outside of just you know
direct you know data scientists or
anybody on a direct data science team uh
maybe your career is in cyber security
um you may be kind of obliged going
forward to at least know something about
AI or machine learning because those are
becoming more and more important um one
example um I was brought in on this and
this was in the news so I can tell you
guys about this I'm not breaking any
kind of like NDA to tell you this so
Chick-fil-A rather large fast food chain
at least here in the US I don't know how
big they are everywhere um so they have
an app like everybody does these days
and their app actually was breached uh
so um they were kind of unaware of this
that this was a possibility but yeah
they uh experienced what's called a
credential stuffing attack where
frauders buy credentials that have been
compromised in these like massive lists
um a fraudster knows you know at any
given time one of these lists that
they've bought maybe only one or two %
of the credentials that they have in
that list are actually you know good so
you basically build a bot that just very
quickly like stuffs everything on the
list through this login portal just to
see what works right just to see like
what credentials actually can get you in
um and there are clear signs when this
is happening that a machine learning
model can identify and can just kind of
cut off that traffic and stop the
credential stuffing attack from
happening uh but that's again if you are
aware that that's a threat and that you
should have a solution for that kind
kind of thing which Chick-fil-A at the
time didn't know so uh yeah I'm actually
on a
team that is talking to Chick-fil-A
right now about what kind of solutions
uh can we put in place to protect the
login portal for their uh for their app
uh and the the primary thing that we're
looking at and that's partly why I'm
involved is a machine learning solution
that can identify when traffic is
malicious and just just cut that off so
uh yeah so I think it's going to be a
very very big part
and yes shockingly I can understand like
frauders trying to hack into like
banking portals or you know like HR
portals like payor ADP where there's a
lot of sensitive information about
people in there but apparently even our
reward points for chicken nuggets aren't
safe uh you know FR like someone
actually like took the time and effort
to like make a bot and like mount a
credential stuffing attack to breach the
Chick-fil-A app so you know you really
have to kind of have protection in place
for everything and it's too much for a
single human or for even a team of
humans to monitor you need to utilize Ai
and machine learning to to watch out for
that so yeah it's definitely going to be
moving into that space more and more but
I don't think it's going to take
anyone's job I think you just kind of
have to be more more aware of it thank
you so much for answering that so now
moving on uh thank you so much for
answering that
Jeremy am you audable yeah you bet
awesome uh so we have talked about the
skills we have talked about the career
paths and uh you are here because
basically you are interested in IML so
what exactly is the biggest challenge
here when it comes to taking up a career
uh in AIML or becoming ANL expert so
what's stopping you from becoming an
AIML expert you can see a quick PO on
your screen this is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options because there can be multiple
concerns right uh so I'll just read out
those options for you uh the first one
being I can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum uh second
one I don't have the practical exposure
I need to become job ready third one I
find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos and the last one my
work shedule won't allow me enough time
for Learning and as I was speaking folks
have already started sharing their
biggest challenge bigest concerns on the
poll here so I'll just give uh I think
15 seconds more for folks other folks to
share their responses and also in case
this poll does not cover your concern or
challenge you are facing uh when you
basically are trying to Aspire a career
in a or transition towards it you can
let us know in the Q&A box or in the
chat box also so that is also totally
okay so I think I'll just give 10
seconds more uh for a few of the folks
who are yet to share with us and also
folks uh thank you for your interesting
questions we getting on the Q&A box uh
we will be addressing them uh shortly
and please uh if you have any questions
you can let us know in the Q&A box we'll
be taking the questions pretty
soon
okay I think most of the folks have
already shared what exactly is the
biggest challenge here let me quickly
end the poll in 5 seconds uh so 5 4 3 2
1 and also share the result with you
folks so as we can see that we have
gotten uh 54% of the votes here for I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and 39% of the
folks have shared uh I can't find a
program with a fully compreh has a
curriculum and 20% of the folks have
shared my work won't allow me enough
time for Learning and 177% of the folks
have shared a find difficult to learn
from pred video so thank you so much for
sharing that with us your biggest
challenge here when it comes to taking
up a AIML career so uh let me introduce
you to the utas AIML machine learning
boot camp here so uh it comes with a
comprehensive industry align curriculum
uh you get access to integrated handsome
labs and projects uh online virtual
classrooms and this program will be
flexible to fit your lifestyle in casee
you're a working professional which we
saw a lot of you almost 40% of you were
having more than five years of
experience um The Learning format here
is online and uh you uh can complete
this program in six months and you can
this completed by giving 10 to 15 hours
per week uh also at the end of it all
you get a utus academic Excellence V
Camp certificate as you can see on the
screen here uh by Eric Johnson School of
Engineering and computer science of
University of Texas and Dallas uh core
and effective core certificates all also
you'll be getting through this program
and UT Circle membership uh you get to
be a part of Learners who basically come
from you know different different
Industries and also different companies
uh and uh you you will be basically
getting a recognition and an online
convocation so you can not only invite
your closest friends and family but also
far relatives and far friends so that's
pretty interesting about part about the
online convocation Here Also let's talk
about the UT delis Advantage here so the
University of Texas at Dallas uh is a
renowned institution with a rich history
of academic Excellence uh it is home to
distinguished faculties and members
researchers forting an environment of
innovation and learning and uh it is
consistently recognized as one of the
top tier research universities providing
students with Cutting Edge knowledge and
resources and how having a uist uh
basically uh University on CV is highly
respected and acknowledged globally open
do to many diverse careers and
opportunities and
networks uh so I think someone asked
about what is the eligibility and
recites so uh in this you need to have a
prior experience in our knowledge of
mathematics and programming and uh a
high school diploma or
equivalent uh at least 18 years of age
and two or more years of work experience
is preferred uh it's preferred it
doesn't have to be necessarily it's good
to have an experience so uh Jeremy just
I'm pretty sure that
aspiring set of Learners you know might
have this question in mind that folks
who don't have that much knowledge in
mathematics and programming uh like what
level of knowledge or experience are we
expecting them to have and if not like
the program does cover a lot of it right
like it introduces you to the basic
concepts as well so can you tell us a
little bit about
that yeah so
um I would say in terms of the
math uh probably what you can do is
maybe just brush up on some your
probability and statistics uh just to
make sure that you're comfortable with
that kind of thing because in data
science um yeah those are really kind of
the core especially basian statistics
basian probability uh are really sort of
the uh kind of core idea within machine
learning right that you can kind of have
you know prior beliefs about data you
can observe more or about about a
certain process observe data about the
process and update your beliefs um I
mean that's really kind of how it all
works so you'll want to be very familiar
with that um the things that we will
probably uh that that you probably will
will be a little bit Rusty on at least
but that we can kind of help you out
with once you get into the program would
be uh linear algebra and calculus
so uh in order to be able to efficiently
compute the the data sets that we have
and the inputs that we have uh data sets
are actually treated as vectors and
matrices
um and actually you'll find that a lot
of these models um you can translate
kind of like what happens on like a
perase basis to dealing with the whole
data set actually as like matrix
multiplication or like Matrix Vector
products things like that uh and that's
how we actually do the compute step of
this as efficiently as possible so
that's not a thing that that we expect
you to know coming in that's a thing
that definitely can be kind of explained
to you or taught to you and same with uh
with Calculus bit and there actually
isn't
a ton of calculus it really is just
derivatives um that uh that you would
have to know in order to calculate what
are called the gradients that allow you
to train the model using the uh
numerical method that that's used to
train these types of models uh
programming I would say just sort of
some basics in uh in Python which is
actually very uh relatively easy highle
language so compared to something like C
or
C++ uh quite a bit easier to pick up
in terms of the specific packages or
tools that
are uh used in data science like the
numpy stack like tensorflow things like
that we also uh cover that kind of stuff
in the curriculum so you don't need to
be an expert in programming or anything
like that already to come
in uh thank you so much for answering
that and giving a detailed explanation I
think we'll be talking more about the
program how exactly It prepares you uh
moving on to that uh so uh the program
how does it build your aim skills step
by step can you take us through that
yeah absolutely so
um yeah so we start kind of at the
bottom here of this visualization with
the orientation which more than anything
actually just kind of lays the
groundwork for you know what's what can
you expect from the program what does
the program expect from you to be
successful all that kind of stuff um
then you get sort of a higher level
introduction to artificial intelligence
so uh at this stage you don't get like a
deep dive into any of the math or the
theory it's more about kind of um at a
high level what is it what kinds of
things could it be applied to uh that
kind of stuff um then the next course
apply data science with python um really
is kind of more about uh how do you
think about the data right uh how do you
deal with different things that show up
in real data sets like missing values
outliers uh how can those sort of things
throw off your analysis what do you do
about it um we look into visualization
libraries to kind of um show you what
one you kind of need to communicate to
yourself what's happening in the data as
you're looking at it uh but also how do
you communicate findings to others uh so
that's a lot of what's covered in that
class then we get into machine learning
which is sort of your first I
think uh kind of proper Deep dive into
the theory of anything uh although
the machine learning algorithms that are
covered there are more what would be
called sort of classical machine
learning so that would be like linear
regression logistic regression um random
forests you know which are based on
decision trees support Vector machines
that kind of stuff um then once you guys
kind of have that Foundation of these
different classical machine learning
algorithms uh we actually then extend
that into deep learning which involves
uh neural networks so that comes up in
the class deep learning with Caris and
tensorflow uh Caris and tensorflow being
sort of the current gold standard
Frameworks for uh building deep learning
models uh then we get into kind of again
current Cutting Edge uh Essentials of
generative AI prompt engineering and
chat
GPT uh so when it comes to large
language models and generative AI um
it's probably not the case that you will
actually be building a model like that
from scratch um
because of just the time and the the
cost involved I mean the the CEO of open
AI has actually said at least roughly it
costs them about a billion to develop
gp4 uh which is the model behind chat
GPT most companies don't have a billion
dollars uh to develop a model and so
when it comes to generative AI
applications you're usually not building
your own model you're instead figuring
out uh how do you use existing models
right so how do you engineer your
prompts to be as specific as possible to
really control you know are we getting
the output we want out of the model um
and different Frameworks for how do you
kind of orchestrate things with a you
know an an llm uh or you know how do you
communicate with it how do you have
different agents that route different
things all that kind of stuff um so
that's what that last class is about uh
and
then finally you get to your Capstone
project which I should mention as well
this isn't the first time that you would
get like hands-on experience in the
program uh so there are projects and
assignments that are Hands-On that you
would need to do uh in a lot of these
classes especially from I would say
machine learning on that's really when
you kind of get into projects that start
to look like real projects um but then
finally all of that everything you've
learned is kind of taken together in
this big final Capstone project at the
end uh which really does uh look like
kind of more of an industry type project
that you might work
on uh thank you so much for taking us to
the steps uh jery also the electives
here the advanced learning and Machine
Vision NLP and speech recognition
reinforcement learning Duty board master
classes you get access to as electives
are optional and they come as a part of
the program uh but it is up to you if
you want to take them uh and we don't
charge anything extra for it it comes as
a part of the program fee so the tools
and platforms which you'll be learning
in this program as you can see python ma
Django open CV caras uh tens of flow for
and many more uh tools and platforms
will be covering this program uh for
Jeremy for someone who completely is
coming from a different background uh
what do you suggest for them to start
with you know maybe like one of the
tools you can tell us
about um I would say the first thing is
just to Learn Python just to understand
like you know what are the data
structures in Python what are the sort
of control flows within python uh
because everything really is sort of
based on that uh and actually a lot of
things too as you get into certain
certain packages like say tensorflow or
Caris
um the syntax that you'll encounter is
like suddenly very different so uh yeah
it's kind of like um you really will
will sort of need like specific
instruction and you do get that
especially in the Deep learning with
Caris in tensor flow um of course we do
cover specifically like um sort of like
how does this particular package ref
framework uh work um so some of these
others like pyit learn again we'll cover
that in the machine learning course um
the syntax recy it learn is actually
very easy but that has a lot of like
very solid very robust implementations
of uh different classical machine
learning models
um D jeno and flask are very useful uh
but they definitely come later so I
would say don't worry about that prior
to the starting of the class um where
these come up is if you're going to
operationalize a model uh depending on
how the model is going to be used and
you know a number of different things a
very common way that you would actually
deploy or operationalize a model is
you'll uh put it in an API and then
there will be documentation for you know
whoever needs to interface with your
model for how they call the API how they
send inputs into the model and then what
kinds of outputs they can expect to come
out um Jingo and flask are among other
things they're used in web development a
lot but they actually do have very nice
implementations for apis so that's why
we use them in data science um and then
yeah map plot lib is actually sort of
the basis for um visualization again
we'll we'll cover that uh you don't need
to make sure that that's you know a
thing you already know coming in um and
then same with yeah some of these other
ones open CV or nltk the nltk stands for
the natural language toolkit um it's
actually a massive framework in and of
itself uh but basically all the
different tools that you would have for
any kind of natural language processing
come bundled up quite nicely in that
package
uh thank you so much for taking us to
the tools and platforms you'll be
learning in this program Journey now
moving on the Capon projects which we
already uh you have talked about how
does having a Capstone project in in
your CV once you're done with the
program helps you showcase your feature
employees the true experience uh in your
portfolio you can choose from SE several
domains here uh in this particular
program the projects combine real world
business requirements with virtual labs
for Hands-On learning and cap projects
are Reg and provide great examples for
your
portfolio also we have industry aligned
projects for your portfolio like human
resources e-commerce automobile Food
Service Healthcare we cover a lot of
different domains here in this industry
line projects which you also can work on
and many more uh which this program
covers and also uh we'll be taking you
through the learning environment of this
program uh so jery can you take us
through the learning environment of the
program and also uh meanwhile you are
preparing to share your screen uh like
I'm just uh put on a few questions for
you in the chat in case you have time we
can answer those as well as you think
that okay for sure uh yes so let's see
let me go ahead and share my screen and
I'll walk you guys through what it looks
like
see do that also uh folks we are getting
a lot of interesting questions from you
in the Q&A box we'll be taking those
pretty soon and we'll try to address as
many questions as possible also in the
meantime yep all right are you guys able
to see uh See my
screen please let us know in chat folks
if you're able to see the
screen yes it's visible I think we
getting yes okay very good okay so this
is our learning management system um so
when you log in this is the the first
place where you will land um so I have a
couple of
different programs here that I've uh
been teaching in uh let's walk through
this one with Caltech because this is
actually Far and Away the most similar
one to what you're looking at here in
fact this
is uh yeah nearly identical so uh
basically you click on that it initially
takes you to your courses uh if you
again need some things that you need a
refresher on like programming or math
you can find that in the
prerequisites um but the core courses
you can find here so uh the they're all
given in order so you can see in this
one there's sort of like an orientation
or
introduction um and then an introduction
to artificial intelligence uh there is
an introduction to python as well for
data science here um then we get into
the applied uh data science with python
machine learning deep learning with
Caris and tensor flow uh and then in
this particular program uh we got into
some Advanced uh deep learning and
computer vision and then finally the
Capstone project so uh your layout here
will be extremely similar although the
particular class list that you see will
be just a little bit different because
of your particular program uh then you
can find any of the electives that Rasha
mentioned here uh so in this particular
one we had statistics uh NLP and speech
recognition reinforcement learning uh
and then an artificial intelligence
master class as well that were totally
optional um and at no extra charge for
the students who did that and then your
certification uh you can also see here
once you've unlocked it um so I didn't
do any of the projects because I'm
teaching the course so so mine's not
unlocked um so that
is um largely what that looks like and
then to kind of give you guys a little
bit of
a let's see I might actually have
something interesting to show you guys
here we'll see it may have been it may
have been wiped out because the class is
over but let's see so this is kind of
what the class will look like when you
uh get in so at any time you can
actually go through all of these
different uh sort of pre-recorded
materials that cover a lot of the uh
topics or all of the topics uh and
they're actually covered quite well uh
but then there are the live class
sessions which again this session isn't
active so there won't be anything uh
here but uh there will be sort of a
class schedule laid out you'll see the
across the bottom and then when it's
time for class there will actually be a
big blue button here in the bottom
corner that says attend class so you
click on that that pulls you into the
class um you can find your assessments
here and then
also for the Hands-On coding part which
uh a lot of the time I'll walk students
through particular
things uh let's see this will get reset
on the 6th of November
sure so there might not actually be
anything in here for me to show show you
guys but um we'll see but we actually do
have an entire Jupiter lab environment
in here uh where we can walk through
exercises in class and also where you
can experiment with different things oh
cool there is something here yeah
so um so this actually is a notebook uh
that I coded up live with this class
where we actually went
through um a feed forward artificial
neural network architecture so we Ed
only numpy and matap plot lib just to
kind of really show kind of the inner
workings like how do these you know how
do these models work so different cells
are kind of doing different things so
here we're defining our activation
functions our objective
functions uh our metrics which we only
did R squ and accuracy for this
example quick little
pre-processing function linear
regression for comparison down the road
and then and Yep this is our actual feed
forward artificial neural network uh
model definition here so these are all
the different things that
uh go into the training so there's a do
fit method here that trains the model
and then we have some internal methods
here the forward train and forward
predict and then finally a predict
method uh and then we also have an auto
encoder here that we implemented so we
implemented these live in class and then
simulated some data and yeah ran through
kind of fitting the model uh different
things kind of conducted some different
experiments so yeah so that's that's the
kind of thing that you can sort of
expect uh going into classes that you'll
have access to this environment which is
currently running python
3.10 uh and it has all the packages you
would need to do you know super cool
data science stuff
so all right so that is our stop sharing
that's our tour
of the learning management system
uh thank you so much Jeremy for taking
us to the learning environment uh so uh
folks we just covered the learning
environment here now moving on to the
learner outcomes here so uh as I've
mentioned ear the Learners of basically
in the previous classes have consisted
of Learners from World Class
organizations and diverse Industries
Industries like it software product
manufacturing farma and Healthcare BFS
and many others and companies which they
come from ASAP Co ra fago Target seens
INF IBM HP and many more Industries like
that uh we also offer I think someone
asked if they we actually help with uh
you know assisting in job for someone
who basically is coming from an N3 level
uh having no experience in Ami before so
simply learn does provide careers
Services which basically helps you with
uh job source uh where you get access to
uh free access to expert webinars and
career events with industry leaders
option to choose from Real World
projects across Industries and create a
portfolio of projects job assess
Services we have partners with tent Inc
here uh basically which starts uh at
boot camp completion uh you know and is
valid for 6 months in the job assess
Services here by talting uh you get
access to job portal uh resume rabbit uh
Service uh and uh basically resume
review and rewrite service from Top
resume and one-on-one interview service
from uh top interview uh so I think uh
we have one question here very
interesting question here I just put it
down for you on the chart here because
youve gotten a lot of questions that
might be hard to navigate uh so J I put
down a question for you I think this is
from Steve what I can make out from the
email ID here correct me if I'm wrong uh
as a forensic auditor uh and a fraud
examiner and member of Association of
certified fraud examiners ACF what
supplement skills do you think fraud
professionals should work on to increase
the knowledge in the existing AIML
environment uh yeah it's an excellent
question so I would say probably the
best thing you could do as someone who
professionally uh detects and prevents
fraud is to just make yourself familiar
with the different machine learning
models that are used in fraud detection
and anomaly detection uh
so that would be you know models within
the supervised learning uh sort of
category so uh really anything that does
classification uh you know all the way
from you know the easiest ones like
naive base classifiers or um logistic
regression all the way up into
artificial neural networks and in some
you know deep learning architectures
like resex is kind of a current hot one
right
now uh you'll definitely want to
understand kind of the limitations and
strengths and weaknesses of uh each of
these
models uh and there are even
some uh unsupervised and reinforcement
learning algorithms that are also uh
common commonly used in this space as
well so I think uh as someone who
already is kind of a deep expert in
fraud it sounds like um if you just
understood how the algorithms work you
would be positioned to actually be like
a real force uh for preventing fraud
because the algorithms
themselves um so for example say like a
gaussian mixture model everyone has
access to what a gaussian mixture model
is um the real key to making sure that
it works well is understanding what are
going to be the best most informative
features you could engineer out of the
data uh to to fit that model too right
and that's true of anything right like
random Forest neural networks whatever
um that really is kind of the thing that
separates like okay data scientists from
like really great data scientists are
the ones that know how to engineer the
best features out of the data and yeah
if you someone who is a forensic auditor
a fraud examiner um you know you're
going to have a real clear idea of like
what are some powerful things to look
for and the data that you could feed to
your model as inputs so um yeah I think
if you kind of combine those two skill
sets of an expertise and fraud with some
knowledge about how these machine
learning models work uh I mean you could
do all kinds of cool
stuff yeah I think thank you so much for
giving a detailed explanation jery I
think Steve says got it thanks jery uh I
think we'll take one more question uh as
we promis I'll will take some questions
before we move forward uh I think uh
this is from MTA I can I can't make out
the name please correct me if I'm wrong
what opportunities and role do you see
in AIML for 20 25 plus years experience
in software consulting services and
management
area um so I would say the opportunity
is huge
um since the since the release of chat
GPT a lot of you know different experts
in the field have kind of updated their
um forecasts for like how big this
industry or this space is going to be uh
and any of the estimates are massive so
on the more conservative side some
people think it's only going to be about
seven trillion uh other people think
it's double that so but you know no
one's really debating that this is going
to be in the trillions of dollars uh so
it's going to be a massive massive space
um and I think there are going to be a
lot of opportunities for you know people
who want to you know who are very
curious uh who are very keen to apply
the scientific method to things that it
has not traditionally been applied to
like business processes um and
hypothesis about businesses and markets
and things like that um so yeah I think
there's a lot of opportunity and a lot
of money to be made um but I should also
warn you guys like that's sort of not
the best reason to get into it um so my
background in education uh was in
mathematics so my degrees in mathematics
I'm kind of a you know a mathematician
and have been a mathematician before I
became a data scientist so I got into
this field because I just actually
genuinely love mathematics I think it's
a lot of fun to build models about
things that you know can accurately
describe things and that can make
accurate predictions about things I mean
it's like actually a thing I kind of get
like a thrill from doing like that you
see that your model is making like
accurate predictions about this thing
that's that's happening um I just think
that that's really really cool and then
it just also happens that you know I I I
got lucky and that you can actually have
a career and make money doing it um
those are the people that I think really
do make the best data scientists and
that really kind of achieve the most and
that are sort of the most fun to work
with um you know it's kind of like
anything else right like if you just get
into it for the money um you're probably
not going to enjoy it that much you're
not going to work that hard at it um you
know uh you can you can kind of only
tolerate so much so if you're if you're
like I hate math um but I want to make a
lot of money there are other ways to
make a lot of money uh so so you know
that's that's just kind of something to
think about is you know do you really
like this kind of
thing definitely uh thank you so much
for answering that Jeremy and giving us
a detailed explanation uh Mah please let
us know uh if that answers your question
if you have any followup question you
can let us know in the chat or in the
Q&A box you taking more questions here
uh so we have talked about the skills
here we have talked about uh basically
what career paths what are the hottest
ending career paths you can Aspire for
uh you know inl in 2024 uh so uh like
would we would like to know are you
interested in enrolling to the UDS AIML
boot camp and also let's not forget
you're getting a bonus offer also for
attending this webinar so I'm just
launching a quick poll here uh please do
let us know here you can see quick two
quick options here so please share with
us your interest towards enrollment into
the UTS AIML boot camp here we'll be
taking a lot few more questions here
after this and I'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program and what is the program schedule
upcoming cohat uh what is the program
fee program structure and we'll be
talking more about that and taking few
more uh questions here U so meanwhile I
just keep this poll live for 15 seconds
more for folks who are sharing their
interest uh about the
program Also let's not forget the bonus
offer you'll be getting for basically
attending this webinar here also uh in
case you are planning to uh basically
join the program maybe in coming months
you're not sure when to start exactly so
don't worry about that we have like a
cachs throughout the year and obviously
we'll be uh you know asking you when do
you plan to enroll as well just to get
an idea so uh you can Avail the bonus
offer anytime you know throughout the
year as well so you don't have to worry
about that so yeah you have talked about
the industry aligned projects you have
talked about the Capstone projects you
can add to your portfolio and having UT
list on your portfolio will definitely
enhance your profile and take it to
another level and uh basically having a
uist university on you CV will
definitely uh you know give you that
prestigious accomplishment you're
looking for so let's I can see a lot of
interest coming towards enrollment so
that's great but I think I'll just give
50 seconds more for the W for for for
folks who are still thinking about it
meanwhile let's utilize this time let's
utilize this time because we are moving
towards the Q&A part of the session uh
we have we I can see few more questions
from the folks here but please do put go
and put down your questions because you
have joined the session so I'm pretty
sure you have a lot of questions about
ai ai future AI career how to transition
into AI you know you can let us know in
the Q&A box so let's utilize this time
and put down your questions in the Q&A
box as we moving towards uh taking your
questions and addressing them
yeah awesome I think I can see folks
have already shared uh responses on the
poll here so I think I'll just give 10
seconds
more okay uh so um you can let us know
are you interested in Rolling to the UTS
boot cam to the quick poll you see on
your screen here would you like to
enroll into the program and uh I'll just
give 5 Seconds more uh so 5 4 3 2 1 let
me quickly end the poll and thank you so
much for sharing uh your interest
towards enrollment of the program I saw
a lot of interest so let me take you
through the enrollment steps here so uh
you basically the program fee uh here
for the program is $88,000 and uh if uh
you are looking for financing options
those are also available for as low as
$74 per month I'll just quickly share
the program link with you folks here
because I saw a lot of you folks have
joined from different regions apart from
us as well so you can check out the fee
for your own region in this link here
which I've shared for the program a IML
boot camp program uist and also if you
have any questions you can basically uh
reach out to us at
ask.net uh I'm just sharing that email
ID also here for you to basically keep a
note of it in case you have any
questions and uh let's talk about the uh
basically program schedule so the
induction classes for this one is
starting on January 8th
2024 that is next year and the classes
also will be starting on January 8 uh
you need to follow three simple steps
for enrollment you need to submit an
application to us at ask using.net uh
based on that your application will be
going for review based on the
eligibility and prequisites which we
have already shared with you and uh Bas
on that you'll be getting admissions
offer letter from siar and learning
Consultants from C be reaching on to you
so uh folks who have already shared with
us uh their enrollment interest we would
love to know uh how soon be your plan to
enroll you can see a quick pulling your
screen uh this will give us an idea when
exactly we need to reach out to you uh
with the admissions offer letter so uh
for folks who are looking for immediate
upcoming cohort which we have already
shared January 8th uh 2024 next year so
you can choose that one uh in case you
are still thinking about it and not are
not sure basically when do you plan to
enroll maybe next three months within
six months or maybe more than six months
from now you have other three options to
choose from so you can quickly choose
from these options this will give us a
better idea about you know when do you
plan to enroll and when exactly uh we
need to reach out to
you okay I think I'll just give 10
seconds for this poll here as folks are
sharing when do they plan to
enroll
okay I think U I think I can see most of
the folks have already shared their
responses in the poll here so I'll just
quickly end it in 5 seconds because we
have exceeded few minutes of the session
here uh so I just end the poll here and
thank you so much for sharing that with
us and as we have addressed a lot of
your queries uh you know during the
session itself so uh we would actually
also love to know when if you need
assistance in enrolling to the program
so there are two quick options here for
folks to have shared interest towards
enrollment and also have let us know
when do you plan to enroll please do
share your responses for the poll here
this is the poll for those folks
here
okay I think I'll give 10 10 seconds
more for the poll here before we move
towards the end of the session uh we
have exceeded few minutes of the webinar
here so so sorry for that we tried
adding uh you know as many queries as
possible throughout the
session I think uh I can see responses
on the poll here I'll just give 5
Seconds for few of the folks who are
still uh basically sharing the responses
so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll
uh so we are towards the end of the
session so uh thank you so much Jeremy
taking the time out and taking us
through this interesting uh you know
AIML master class uh would you like to
say something to the folks here before
we end the
session um yeah just thank you so much
everybody for uh taking the time um so
it's been a lot of fun fun to talk to
you guys about this to answer your
questions um and I really hope that you
guys uh you know start your journey on
becoming a data scientist or machine
learning learning engineer and I think
that really you know this is the way to
do it right so if you think about it I
mean it took me a long time right you
know years of studying math at
University um I saw the other day on
LinkedIn someone put a thing that was
like become a data scientist in 30 days
and I was curious so I clicked on it and
kind of looked into it more and they
were like oh you can spend like three
days learning linear algebra and then
spend like four days learning calculus
and I was just like that's insane like
that so hopefully everybody here kind of
realizes like that's not real right you
can't really can't really do this in
like 30 days uh but there's got to be
some kind of happy medium between like
could you do this whole thing in 30 days
or you know do you have to spend years
at a university and really a program
like this partnered with the university
that's you know anywhere from six months
to a year some of our programs are a
year long I mean that's realistic right
like that's actually like a you know
realistic like comprehensive program so
uh you know I really think this is kind
of the you know the way to go about
doing it so yeah it's my two cents on it
thank you so much jery once again uh so
uh thank you so much for joining we just
have like a quick survey for them if you
want you can leave I just want to
basically understand what topic of our
areas of Interest they would like to see
covered in the future webinars so I've
quickly launched a foler so I'll just
need one minute from you folks uh just
to understand what exact ly you would
want to see in the future webinars from
Simply uh so this is a multiple choice
poll so you can select multiple options
and submit it so I'll just read out
those options for you we have pretty
interesting options here so uh I think
we today we covered uh industry Trends
sort of uh you know specific insights in
the session and I see that you know what
an interesting session that was and we
would love to do more of these so you
can see these options here so Pro
program project demos uh soft skill
development resume enhancement interview
and tips in Trends industry specific
insights tools platforms Library
Workshop personal branding networking
case studies career advancement strategy
so you can let us know in this quick
survey poll here what topics or areas of
Interest would you like to see covered
in the future webinars on simply learn
so this will really help us uh you know
as we do a lot of these webinars
throughout the month and uh we you
usually have a lot of these webinars
with jemy as well and we have tried a
lot of webinars with you like project
demo and Industry specific uh you know
um webinar and career master class and
program preview so uh we would love to
know what exactly are you looking for
when you basically come to these
webinars here and we would love to make
it much more exciting much more
interesting for you much more valuable
you know when you are giving us these 60
minutes and ATT attending this webinar
here so and also I saw that the audience
was pretty patient here like you know
they actually stayed throughout even
though we extended the session I saw
that uh so you can let us know in case
the survey does does not cover what you
want you can let us know in the chat or
in the Q&A box as
well uh I can see someone has replied to
us that I would love to roll immediately
but because of my background in
engineering uh but my financial
commitment would not allow that so uh
like the go is anyway starting in
January 8th and there are many more
upcoming cohorts for this program and we
have financing optionals available as
well in case you want to you know uh
utilize those options so uh please do
let us know you can write it write to us
at ask us simple.net if basically you
need more Assistance or want to
understand I'm just sharing that on the
chat once again here and I think folks
have already shared a lot of responses
for the survey poll so thank you so much
for taking few minutes for this this
will give us an understanding what
exactly you want in these webinars I
I'll end the poll uh and I'll just
quickly share that uh we actually got
50% of the work for career advancement
strategies 41% for Trends that's
interesting 45% for soft skills and 41%
for tools platforms libraries so I think
we will work on that and basically will
will be applying in the upcoming
webinars thank you so much thank you so
much once again Jeremy I saw that you
were closely looking at the survey
question so I think we will have a
discussion about that pretty soon for
the upcoming webinars but thank you so
much thank you so much folks have a good
day good evening good morning uh
afternoon wherever you're joining
thank
you yep thanks
everybody